Israel and the United States have a
special relationship unprecedent so
special that Israel gets more than half
of all US foreign aid what kind of aid
are we talking about and more
importantly why does the u.s. keep it
flowing this is the real deal on US aid
to Israel simply put the u.s. gives
Israel money lots of it to be precise a
grand total of 121 billion dollars and
Counting and unlike USA to most other
countries money to Israel is given
primarily to its military why the
security of Israel preventing a nuclear
Iran and ending the israeli-palestinian
conflict but it's a military that has
been accused of war crimes by the United
Nations and called trigger-happy by
Amnesty International no matter as
foreign policy analyst Stephen wall puts
it the United States gives Israel
generous diplomatic economic and
military support and does so
unconditionally regardless of what it
does and the support comes in many forms
first there's a US budget Congress gives
Israel on average three billion dollars
a year three billion dollars of US
taxpayers money Uncle Sam also doles out
more aid by funding military research
programs in 2014 504 million dollars
went to joint u.s. Israeli military
research and to the development of anti
rocket defense systems one of those
systems Iron Dome has cost the u.s. 720
million dollars a price tag that is
going up as we speak
then there are the additional
multi-million dollar weapons deals we're
talking hundreds of millions of dollars
here and a billion dollar US weapons
stockpile that Israel can access in
times of emergency all in all with the
USS help Israel has one of the
advanced militaries and is one of the
top ten arms dealers in the world yes
who's one of its biggest customers the
United States the relationship is
lucrative as Phyllis Bennis of the
Institute for Policy Studies says it
started in 1967 after the six-day war
when the Pentagon initiated a new
relationship the Israeli military was
very powerful Pentagon looked at them
and said wow we could do business with
these people and business became the
operative term what about non-military
aid USAID has given more to Israel than
it has to any other country in the
Middle East helping to build libraries
medical centers and universities talk
about friends-with-benefits the US says
that arming Israel helps protect it from
Hamas fighters in Gaza Hezbollah
fighters in Lebanon and of course Iran
but Hamas has rockets and Israel has
f-16s and while Iran has no confirmed
nuclear warheads Israel has an estimated
80 so after all the military aid is
Israel really as vulnerable as the US
says it is and is all this money
actually helping to end the
israeli-palestinian conflict if it were
cut what might change in Israel might be
willing to rethink the occupation
rethink settlement building and perhaps
get more interested in a two-state
solution right now they don't have to
compromise because they get backing from
the United States no matter what they do
so what do you think is this special
relationship
worth the price